hi guys I'm down here at Game Developers
Conference establishing my awesome indie
Street Fred with the independent games
festival these guys last night have
their own awards show over some of them
one thousands of dollars in cash prizes
for their amazing games some of which
were created by teams of one to three
people we're going to go talk to some of
the winners and some of my favorite
games from the show and they are going
to explain to us why they are so awesome
ah my name is Phil I'm an independent
game developer for all of five days now
I believe and this is our game called
Fez because of because of the hat that
the character wears it's a platforming
game it's a puzzle platforming game that
uses a 2d to 3d world rotation mechanic
but the gameplay is always 2d so it's
more like 2d to 2d to 2d you never play
3d your a flat man a 2d being exploring
a 3d world from a student perspective we
want for excellence in visual art
because it's so pretty I am Joseph Tkach
I'm from Southern California and this is
our game sinister it's a student project
it's a psychedelic rhythm based shooter
so it's kind of a mesh of geometry wars
and dance dance revolution is how we
like to think of it but our big
inspiration was res we love tattoo
mizuguchi I love everything he's done
and this is really kind of a homage in a
little way I think to res you move
around using WA s and D and that's how
you dodge enemies and then you use jkl
kind of like a guitar hero type of thing
and you follow the rhythm so you shoot
by following the rhythm and
you move by using last it's a kind of an
experience in multitasking but it works
surprisingly well it's not as
complicated as it sounds we won the best
student showcase and man I did not think
that was going to happen it was quite an
experience hey guys we're down you
taking a look at cran physics to lock
switch to the grand prize winner of the
independent games festival the designer
is not here he's off doing a session
which is a disappointment because I love
it if he could show you this amazing
game he won $25,000 grand prize for this
which is good so let's take a look at
friend physics deluxe as you can see
anything you draw on the screen turns
into an object with real physics whether
you draw a ball or a box or a line or
some sort of weird indistinct object
game recognizes how big it is what size
it is and it starts acting with real
physics so the object is to get the ball
all the way over to the star on the
other end of the screen the puzzle start
out as you can see the puzzle start out
very simple but they get very very
complicated as the game goes on it's
riveting it's really cool hopefully you
guys will be able to check it out
sometime soon
you